- Meetings.
They're the bane of
every office employee
and something you have
to go to regularly
if you want to keep your job.
But that's where your
responsibility ends.
You just have to go.
You don't have to
do much beyond that.
I've developed a few simple ways
to appear engaged in a
meeting, when in actuality,
you're calculating what year
you're gonna die in your head.
First technique, fish face.
You know how fish sleep
with their eyes open?
That's basically what
you're doing here.
Pick a point at the
front of the room
while making your
mind a total blank,
and it's almost
like you're asleep,
except you can
still see everyone,
but my mindfulness app
says it counts as rest.
I know what you're thinking.
What if you're asked
for your input?
Go with something
basic and vague.
I like something like,
"Wow, I've honestly never
thought about it that way,"
or "It sounds like we're at
a natural stopping point,"
or the always risky, "That last
part actually concerns me."
Generally, everyone wants
the meeting to be over
as soon as possible,
so no one will ask you
to expand on what you meant.
But if someone does, you
can always fire back with,
"I think we should try
and get back on track."
Lastly, if you're a
doodler, always doodle
after the person speaking
has made a natural pause.
That way, while it will
appear like you are
diligently taking
notes, you're actually
practicing your signature,
your signature after
you marry Alexander
Skarsgard, I mean.
An old classic.